it was really hard because i didn't like
i'm i'm actually a very shy person
so learning how to sell was the hardest
thing i could do
but if i hadn't spent four years
learning how to sell i never made it
here i never made it here
so the entire time that you were here
you were preparing to jump to the other
correct
so every job is not so much for the high
paying job with job security
for not not everybody and most people
should have job security because
they're not designed to be entrepreneurs
but if you're going to be an
entrepreneur then you better take this
job and say well which way am i going to
go yeah
so i knew
my job at xerox
was to go here and here and here yeah
not stay here
and i actually make so much money over
here that i don't need job security
money
so really that's a lesson when you look
at a job you look at what can i learn
more than how much can i make